here's what would happen if you dumped  an iceberg into an active volcano  well the first thing you'd see is an  immediate blast of steam the meeting of  these two extremes ice and lava would  cause the ice to instantaneously go from  its solid state to a gaseous state  skipping the liquid form  next one of two things could happen  the ice might turn into steam faster  than it can escape creating a massive  steam explosion which would cause the  volcano to explode  alternatively the ice could cool the  surface temperature of the lava the lava  would appear as if it were boiling as  the vapor tried to escape and then it  would harden into a texture like bubble  wrap this hard shell would trap volcanic  gas  over time pressure from the trapped gas  would build up until boom the volcano  blasts its top  so instead of stopping a volcanic  eruption dumping an iceberg into an  active volcano would make the explosion  even worse so